um yeah napoli actually i mean with his  body language you would think he hasn't  seen it but we're back in the critical  position  if he pushes that pawn that corner pawn  up two squares as we saw  he is winning i don't think he sees it i  don't think i would see it either in a  game situation it's so difficult  the whole concept um just to freeze your  opponent and the idea is a bit deep as  well you need to be accurate later on  but look he doesn't spot it  he doesn't have a lot of time though  okay he doesn't find it no i don't think  he's finding it i mean his body porsche  tells me actually that he thinks oh no  i've just  i've squandered the position's about to  repeat itself for a third time  actually it's crazy the position is a  draw here it repeats itself but white is  winning in the final position  it just doesn't see it